comment sortir du chaos migratoires au
fond c'est la question à laquelle nous
allons avec vous essayer de répondre ce
matin d'abord en refusant les postures
on n'est pas ici pour adopter des
postures on refuse à la fois la fausse
générosité de ceux qui prétendraient
accueillir tout le monde sans aucune
condition et on refuse aussi la
brutalité de ceux qui penseraient tous
fermés tout cadenassé on n'est pas dans
les postures
on doit regarder la réalité en face la
réalité des chiffres
bien sûr la réalité des personnes
arrivent à la réalité des évolutions
économiques démographiques géopolitique
la réalité aussi des contraintes
juridiques et c'est en refusant les
postures et en s'attelant à la réalité
qu'on doit tracer un chemin politique
pour définir une action sur
l'immigration à la fois avec des
instruments européens et des instruments
nationaux
on doit être ici le parti des solutions
françois hollande lui c'est un problème
par sa passivité son inaction cette
tergiversation son absence de réflexion
nous on doit construire des solutions
sérieuses et donc entrons dans le vif du
débat avec cette première table ronde
je demande s'il le veut bien
à patrick stefanini de nous de nous
rejoindre
patrick stefanini conclura cette table
ronde en nous éclairant sur les
contraintes juridiques il a été vous le
savez le premier secrétaire général du
ministère de l'immigration
permettez moi de dire d'ailleurs qu'on a
le sentiment un peu de reconstituer
unique 10 août puisque nous étions sous
l'autorité de brice hortefeux tous les
deux acteurs de la construction de ce
ministère il ya déjà il ya déjà huit ans
nadia amour qui est la secrétaire
nationale à l'intégration va également
nous nous rejoindre elle évoquera
l'échec global du système d'intégration
c'est réussit parfois mais son échec
global certainement
pascal perrineau éminent professeur à
sciences po nous éclairera sur au fond
les perceptions de l'opinion publique
sur le défi migratoire
michèle tribalat madame merci de votre
présence vous nous présenterait si vous
le voulez bien au fond la réalité des
chiffres du défi migratoire
natacha bouchart sénatrice et maire de
kehl est chère natasha nous apportera le
témoignage de terrain d'un maire très
courageux confronté à ce défi de manière
extrêmement concrètes dans le calaisis
et last but not least pierre lellouche
délégué général de notre mouvement pour
les questions internationales va
introduire cette table ronde avec le
regard d'expert de la politique
étrangère qui est le sien pierre c'est à
toi aux portes de l'europe
le défi migratoire est là à toi